october is national dessert month so we
send rocky on a really tough assignment
ted and kirsten asked for this
assignment but we sent rocky
learning how to make marie callender's
famous pies
as the restaurant celebrates the kickoff
of their fall
pie sale hey there rocky
hey brian yeah sorry not sorry okay you
guys listen
i've been you left me here by the way we
had you know some time
um with with the governor speaking and
i've been eating shrimp salad i've been
eating pie and
i'm just i'm ready for a nap now but
that's what marie calendars does it's
comfort food
and now for fall it's pie it's dessert
yes and right now we're definitely there
it's on sale
all the pies are on sale starting at
7.99 yes so they can come out and try
it's a great deal yeah it's a great deal
from banana from funkin
you know apple so definitely it's the
time all the classics all the classics
and
of course the fall specials like the
pumpkin you gotta have your pumpkin
everything
okay so what i want to do now is show
you guys how simple it is
to make the famous french apple pie yes
yes definitely you need to start with a
dough make sure you have the right
concentration on the dough uh
after that you make your juice your
chill okay and then you're going to drop
you want to do it
okay drop and i'm not i'm not a i'm not
a baker by any means so this is so make
sure you have the right apples grammy's
meat are the best but you can try
different ones you want oh my gosh yeah
and definitely feel they're all i mean
they're not we're going to uh
what's next what's next yeah and then
you're going to add this one and then
we're going to bake it yeah
okay yeah you can definitely okay
do it all around all right you gotta
make spread it all over
okay and then that's what we have after
we bake it how long do you take to bake
about 45 minutes to pick them up that's
not bad yeah that's right no just make
sure it wouldn't burn
it's also something you can do with your
kids you know family you guys can come
here and also buy the ingredients or buy
the crust and make it yourself yep
yeah definitely if not you need to stop
by and get one yeah
which is what i prefer which is what i
prefer okay and also
what else how else do you guys celebrate
the season here in marine calendars i
know you know well
dinners maybe yeah right yeah yeah
definitely right after price though
we're going through our
thanksgiving when we saw the fees we
actually it's a meal
for four to six people right that you
can just take it home heat it up
and get ready for for the holidays you
know for thanksgiving okay well it's
obviously community favorite a
national favorite everybody loves marie
calendar so i think the two of us
you know since we've been hanging here
all day we should have some pie together
why not you guys definitely do you have
a slice anywhere
i don't have a light bulb oh i'm sorry
i'm it's just because it's
right yep it's just me on fire being
greedy
okay
you can't go wrong no definitely what
separates your pies from
everywhere else well i think uh i'll
take
money it's definitely a homemade we bake
every morning
and all different 20 different flavors
uh so we have a couple locations here in
vegas one henderson
so definitely just to stop by and get
you know get one
get one get two get three yeah that's
right now family parties you know small
group gatherings absolutely all right
thank you so much angel
thank you for encounters guys i will
send it to break and then we'll be back